The worst holiday I ever had actually happened last summer.
I was going to a school trip with my friends and we were going to Barcelona.
So, while we were on the bus,...
...we realized that we weren't actually going to Barcelona.
We were going to the mountains near Barcelona,...
...and it was really uncomfortable while we were there...
...because we hadn't brought the right clothes for it,...
...and because after each day in the mountains, we got soaked.
So, we were really uncomfortable...
...and we complained to the director of the school...
...and to the organizer of the school trip...
...and they apologized, and in the end, they took us to Barcelona for a few days.